bruno vous avez enquêté sur la sphère
tas vous êtes le journaliste vous êtes
le premier à avoir mis cette affaire en
lumière déjà je voudrais qu'on donne la
parole à bruno parce que c'est vrai que
hier on a entendu le témoignage de tommy
qui nous a franchement tous retournés
voilà et tommy avait l'air extrêmement
vraiment voilà sincère donc dans son
témoignage bruno aujourd'hui vous quand
vous avez entendu le témoignage de tommy
hier qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous
avez à répondre de cette histoire et
tout ce qui s'est passé lors de son
interpellation en bas il a très bien
choisi son pseudo tonme c'est pas le
verlan 2,8 au sort je pense que c'est un
menteur tout simplement pourquoi comment
parce qu'on le sentait extrêmement
s'informant sincères y ait une fois oui
mais ça c'est le problème c'est de
sentir j'ai ce tracé très bien vous avez
beaucoup d'empathie en général et que en
général les gens que vous recevez son
comment sont de très bons comédiens donc
donc voilà donc vous ne racontez nous
votre histoire alors pardon racontez
nous votre histoire votre version la
version tout à son vous êtes un
délinquant je crois monsieur z connu des
services de police
oui c'est une question
c'est parce que
[Musique]
le pendant pour hors jeu
vous faites des plateaux télé il
a pu parler
on va laisser aller renault va dérouler
alors qu'elle est déjà j'aimerais savoir
si ce monsieur est un délinquant parce
qu'il a déjà menti
je respecte tout le monde mes projets
avec son casier ou non non je vois la
façon vous avez des trucs intéressants
vous ici que
vous avez parce que ce film nuit si
parallèlement pour donner une histoire
de donner des éléments effectivement
donc finalement vous avez dit que c'est
vous qui avez révélé l affaire jeunes
hommes ont entre autres avec la radiale
street prévoir à la wii est intervenu
sur une autre sur un autre média c'est
moi vous parlez en donc en collaboration
non mais il a d'abord fait une interview
chez lui ou pas
non est ce qu il a fait l'interview
comme on a fait une interview la banque
est la vôtre
dépassés après commune donc donc
maintenant parce que
j'aimerais qu'on est là vers votre
version c'est parce que là on parle pour
rien alors votre perso non mais moi ma
version non monsieur j étais pas je
n'étais pas
sauf que ce monsieur comme d'habitude
arrive sur un plateau télé d'abord un
pour une victime cd c'est moi moi j'ai
travaillé comment sur les victimes de
violences sexuelles elles ont pas du
tout ce comportement c'est à dire que
quand on a été violée je peux vous dire
qu'on se balade pas sur les plateaux
télé je peux vous dire que c'est une
vraie souffrance c'est une vraie
souffrance ou aider chacun à
cent pour cent pour cent des gens que
j'ai entendu hommes ou femmes qui se
sont fait violer je peux vous dire
qu'ils viennent pas raconter ça sur
plusieurs plateaux télé qui ne
fréquentent pas ce genre d'individu qui
déteste la place vous l'avez connu
comment ce monsieur vous l'avez connu
comment monsieur monsieur toubal les
chômeurs dans la salle vous le
connaissiez avant ce monsieur je connais
pas cette partie est ce que vous
connaissiez de streeter
de deux choses l'une soit vous êtes
venus ici avec des éléments mais c'est
pas non mais quand vous êtes venus ici
avec une histoire et des éléments moi
j'ai fait une enquête même on n'est pas
dans un tribunal criminel moi j'ai des
éléments alors moi je suis venu qu'elle
gérait briques donc voilà est à trouver
dans la même enquête avec le média et
streetpress d'accord pour qu'on a réduit
le témoignage de tommy on a fait une
enquête et on a obtenu des éléments ce
que vous n'avez pas je crois d la loi
monsieur certificat médical ainsi
l'interview interdit de faire sable les
certificats médicaux qui vont dans le
sens de sa version mais d ici voilà ils
sont là oui mais je les ai vu ma
démission est remis à l'écran vous les
avez mis sur le chemin vieux monsieur
selon vous vous êtes vous dit que c'est
un mythomane oui alors bon déjà là on va
le rapport du docteur donc ces
constatations sont compatibles avec les
déclarations du plaignant une multiples
ecchymoses des hématomes sur le tronc
narre la nuque sur l'abdomen
l'idée fait tout ça la légende un coup
il s'est fait tout seul et je voulais
des éléments vous les révéler mal
zidane est un des éléments alors j'ai
pas le droit de vous les donner parce
que sinon je risque je risque mais vous
savez quoi est ce qu'il faut faire faut
attendre la justice parce qu'ici ça ni
un tribunal ça devient un tribut à
vérifier vous-même ou pas je peux je
vérifier moi nash de tommy hier c'est
dommage
que ce que vous faites là vous faites un
tribunal us i ouverte aussi parce que
vous demander d'aider des éléments que
vous avez des lots vous avez pu les voir
vous dire vous allez poursuivi monsieur
pour dénonciation calomnieuse
je peux vous dire que ce que vous avez
fait est ce que vous avez dit vous avez
mis des policiers en cause vous
inquiétez pas que la justice passera et
qu'on vous poursuivra donc vous avez
occasionnellement comme tous les autres
cas la lumière fois que suivre sans
qualifie que le ps voulait garder les
coulisses apparemment il peut pas donner
les éléments c'est ça mais c'est un vrai
que c'est une enquête on va tous les
bulls à vernier est ce qu'on pouvait
alors de deux choses l'une quand vous
êtes là vous êtes ça vous êtes un
menteur où il y est allé avec ces
éléments et pour cela vous pouvez pas
nous les donner soi et c'est encore plus
grave vous avez enfreint la loi en
complicité avec les policiers du 19e
vous avez eu accès à des éléments d'une
enquête juneau qui en est non alors les
éléments judiciaires
alors
vous avez dit vous avez dit que vous
aviez baisser votre caleçon sera donc du
coup ce que j'ai vu c'est qu'il ya un
internaute vous avez dit que vous aviez
à bombay ton 400 et bc pourtant vous dit
après dans la déclaration que le
policier vous arracher votre caleçon
mais vous l'aviez bc monsieur et ensuite
vous avez changé de version quand même
il faut vérifier moi je travaille je
sais quoi sur les médias c'est pourquoi
parce que je n'ai pas le droit de mettre
mon nez dans l' enquête comme la sphère
est clair je n'ai pas le droit de mettre
mon nez dans l' enquête
si on m'a menacé dans les coulisses mais
j'ai été menacé dans les coulisses j'ai
déposé plainte par qui écoutez moi quand
j'ai pas mon interlocuteur en face par
monsieur anwar on peut le dire à
monsieur
n'a mis qu'un ami à ce monsieur j'ai été
menacé pop parce qu'il voulait divulgué
comment mon intimité donc j'ai déposé
plainte donc j'ai déposé plainte
donc voilà on essaie de la belgique mais
pour cette histoire pour vous tommy a
menti sur toute la ligne mais mes seins
c'est un menteur et la gare donc à paris
plutôt compromettante vous il vous
permet pas s'il vous plaît du simple
jeunes hommes respect si vous commettez
pas pour toi nicolet groupe en tant que
nous n'avons pas de poser devant pascal
à vous inquiéter pas mais aussi chaque
chose en son temps ça ce qui s'est passé
quelque chose du traité de menteur et
poésie toujours vous êtes juste 1 tommy
haas qui transmettait le micro comprends
pas ceux
qui simplement que vous êtes un con
mille fois mieux
vous connaissez très bien la procédure
parce qu'on n'entend pas que j'aime avec
le masque et micro sa mère
c'est le spécialiste de la chute de la
position que j'ai donnée cieux est une
arabe de service monsieur est ce que je
lis et une arabe de service sa toque et
est ce que mon collègue policier
abdoulaye kanté est un domaine très noir
alizé est ce que c'est une serpillière
ou un larbin monsieur va répondre oui
s'il voudrait lui c'est génial parce que
lui avec lui ai pas besoin d enquête
n'ait pas besoin de juges a pas besoin
d'avocat y a pas besoin d'enquêté est ce
qu'il ya eu apparemment
occulter moi j'ai policiers avant même
les enquêteurs du gpn ça c'est pas utile
non mais pardon mais dans ce cas là mais
parce que c'est arnaud sariev et ils
contestent les décisions de justice sur
viry châtillon et c'est donc en fait
avez-vous n'y a pas besoin de juges n'y
a pas besoin d'avocat il pas besoin car
mais moi j'attends mais moi j'attends
des manuels macro et moi j'attends
monsieur genton jallet va les juger mais
le juge flic journalistes et les soeurs
un an des finesses je sais pas un nom
parce que moi je trouve que le spectacle
est absolument effrayant oui d'abord
monsieur vous dit
j'ai beaucoup de respect évidemment pour
la police mais vous dit à monsieur que
c'est un délinquant parce qu'il a un
casier judiciaire comme monsieur éclair
à l'époque et je me souviens que zemmour
avait dit en gros il a un casier donc en
gros bon ben voilà c'est bien fait pour
lui on ne peut pas dire ça monsieur même
si me ce monsieur un casier judiciaire
long comme le bras il n'a pas le droit
d'être agressé la voir mais je voudrais
aussi vous allez commencer vous avez
commencé dans monsieur vous avez un
casier judiciaire parce que j'aurai
savoir la personnalité ce qu'un individu
parce que vous quand vous confiez vos
besoins
une agression ou une
allergie la raison là dessus mais juste
moi j'ai
juste dit ça la réponse de par
spécialité c'est de faire dire ce que je
n'ai pas d'image très
ambitieux pc-bond ya beaucoup de gens
sur les réseaux sociaux qui ont demandé
aussi je vous le dis à ta qui ont dit
comment se fait-il que tommy et étaient
dans une voiture volée
c'est ça qui voit là et ça j'espère dès
l'obtention alors ils ont dit sur 3 m
c'était sur 3 m le refus d'obtempérer
jeune homme
alors
attendons une fois moins bien s'il vous
plaît ok pas de souci on enfants ont vu
vous avez dit qui fermente
aujourd'hui vous êtes là vous êtes le
porte parole de la police ce à dire
qu'il visionnait représenter les deux
policiers en question je ne connais pas
monsieur tu fais du mans mais moi mais
moi je représente la police nationale et
comme en plus j'ai une expérience
vraiment j'ai fait beaucoup d'auditions
de femmes violées et d'hommes violents
et je peux vous dire que
faire du rap et que vous allez j'allais
sortir de cette affaire oui parce que
c'est bon mais
l'avocate de tommy métal elle ne nie pas
les antécédents judiciaires du tout il a
eu plusieurs peines de prison il a eu
plusieurs panels le reconnaît ensuite
elle reconnaît aussi qu'il était qu'il
conduisait une voiture volée et même son
avocat dit c'est l' enquête qui montrera
s'ils savaient au nom de cette voiture
était volée lui dit que notre pote mais
l'enquêté révélera rien ensuite il ya
deux procédures qui sont ouvertes l'igpn
procédures administratives et il ya une
enquête du parquet et monsieur attal
l'avocate de tommy dis moi j'attends les
résultats de l'expertisé l'exploitation
des caméras donc là on sort à des
prélèvements adn et elle veut le
confrontation avec les deux policiers
parce qu'à pas eu confrontation ses deux
fils je sais quand moi je prends pas du
tout partisan des éléments factuels je
trouve quand même que vous vous avancez
sur des éléments factuels que vous
n'avez pas puisque moi j'ai enquêté
aujourd'hui a pas eu la confrontation il
n'y a pas eu l'exploitation des caméras
vous n'avez pas les éléments factuels
vous inquiétez sur quoi monsieur g qui
était sur la procédure vous appelez
l'avocate de mon contradicteur exact
vous fournit juste parce qu'il ya que
l'appelant monsieur bac 2 non maintenant
je l'admets source de quoi vous allez
voir l'avocate c'est comme la sphère est
clair il refile le dossier orfi le
dossier épais nous les policiers on peut
pas se battre parce que nous on a un
devoir de réserve je ne peux pas parler
d'été vous dite circulaire un avoir
pardon est un problème la sphère est
claire rien à jouer non c'est une fuite
en avant
tout sur la chaîne youtube tous publics
sur la 180 jours d'itt et et c'est une
fête nous et comment je vous dis aussi
que monsieur est claire a menti kim
attaque en diffamation allez sur la
chaîne youtube touche pas à mon flic
s'est automutilé monsieur muller par des
données des couilles s'est automutilé
comment mais mon dieu oh mon dieu mais
dites moi il va falloir sortir des gens
c'est
à lui d'aller sur la chaîne moi je vous
donne des arguments à damas temps je
peux pas les expliquer ici et maintenant
ce que vous faites
l'exposition vous les
jours d'itt était en gros d'une michelle
éclair a eu six jours d'itt été sauf que
son avocate regardez sur touche pas à
mon flic la chaîne youtube son avocate a
additionné 80 jours d'itt été suite à
une opération et 90 jours de problèmes
psychologiques donc déjà un ca ne
s'additionnent pas de deux les 80 les
ailes et comment les 90 jours ce ne sont
pas les unités médico judiciaires qui
les ont fourni c'est un médecin donc
c'est à dire que ça n'a pas ce n'est pas
probant au niveau de la justice j'ai
répondu ou pas alors juste pour moi
j'aimerais qu'on vienne à l'histoire de
tommy pour vous tommy a menti sur toute
la ligne oui 2 avec 2 à z il n'a jamais
été violente et non non mais je suis
persuadé que mes collègues mais non mais
attendez mais ça en vaut deux épreuves
moi je n'ai pas confiance en
moi je viens d'être un boom avec aucune
preuve de quoi
je mets ma main pour quelques lectures
vous êtes juste un menteur menteur ici
c'est vous vous avez
toute votre vie ça vous pour tous droits
ont été violés sur
des choses comme ça monsieur moi pardon
peut voir naître votre syndicat du front
national
vous n'êtes pas idiots sur nationale
vous damien rieu à toi vous dites qu'il
faut expulser les étrangers boudent 28
sur 28 / sur 20 c'est vous parler
d'islam au gauchisme et compagnie ça va
deux secondes un moment donné pour
nicolas vous et moi j'ai utilisé le mot
est ce que vous pouvez répondre si linda
cup est une arabe de service s'il vous
plaît
des plus généreux et tommy reçu très mal
est-ce que linda kebab et une arabe de
service vous pouvez répondre c'est pas
le procès d'avoir
un nicolas pernaut rigolo moi j'ai une
question à vous poser il vient sur les
plateaux de manière anonyme il a reconnu
hier qu'elle était avec un véhicule volé
des vitrines machin expliquez-moi en 30
secondes
la stratégie de ce garçon pourquoi il
fait ça vous pouvez expliquer alors je
vais vous poser une autre question
expliquez-moi la stratégie de mes
collègues qui vont être dans une fouille
retirer leurs gants et qui vont lui
mettre un doigt dans le cul et said
spitz humour dont ça existe et vous les
voyez aussi madame mais les deux côtés
les célèbres ou alors ça vous avez pas
d'arguments j'en ai pas donc victoire
655 ans
je peux vous poser une question sauf
vous me répondez avec les éléments que
ça y est ce que vous avez déjà des
éléments de l'enquète qui prouve que
tommy aurait menti d'après vous non non
vous n'en avez pas non j'ai travaillé
sur les vidéos qu'ils ont fait je sais
qu'il est un peu gêné
il a fait plusieurs interviews et donc
du coup elles correspondent pas donc
allez sur le site street ce trio comme
ça donc vous avez un truc camillo
gissinger vos notes voilà louer mais
c'est parce qu'on parle de casiers de
tommy reparler du gaz et du commissariat
du 2ème arrondissement est tristement
célèbre il ya un journaliste qui a
infiltré le commissariat pendant deux
ans et qui racontent ce que tommy en
train de dire c'est à dire des violences
est à dire des violences racistes le
lycéen de berck sonne qui s'est fait
frapper et un policier a été condamné du
comme ça admet oui il ya des mauvais
chez steria 19/10 mans il est connu je
me sens commissariat violent un
commissariat où il y avait des éléments
des gens qui sont racistes et vous venez
nous dire circulez ya rien à voir comme
pour la
sécu 10h dans le 19e c'est un des
commissariats les plus chauds de paris
jeudi devait voir l'histoire ya
stalingrad il ya belle ville qu'est au
dessus c'est un des commissariats moi
j'ai été en garde à vue dans le 19e
effectivement vous les gens en âge des
gens qui sont dans le commissariat du
19e il ya une délinquance dans le 19e
qui est juste ahurissant donc moi je
veux pas défendre la police mais ma
question c'est est ce qu'on est ce que
vous comprenez qu'on puisse juste un
moment remettre peut-être votre que
parole en question et même si je trouve
ça inadmissible mais parce que de la
même manière qu'un juge quand il va vous
recevoir dans son dans son cabinet va
vous dire monsieur je vois vous avez
déjà fait ça ça ça et ça mais cyril quoi
j'ai vous reste warhol s'y risquent ces
suspects c'est juste qu'il faut juste la
prédication solide mais c'est vous le
coupable sur itunes soit je vois je vous
attendais 2000 bruno et de grimpe à vous
excuser moi c'est pas à moi qu'il faut
voir c'est tommy moi j'ai récolté son
témoignage j'ai mis en mis en lumière
des éléments de l'enquète qui vont dans
son sens et à une enquête mais justement
il faut se poser la question de pourquoi
est-ce que des pendant sa garde à vue il
dit à l'officier de police judiciaire
j'ai été violée je veux passer des
examens médicaux ils demandent à passer
des tests adn ils demandent à être
examinés immédiatement à tard il dépose
plainte il a dit regarde cette question
qui revient sans cesse sur les réseaux
sociaux vous le dis c'est pourquoi dans
une voiture volée et c'est pas des
syriens n'ont pas de sang sur le sujet
c'était une location j'ai effectué je
n'avais aucune connaissance étant bien
même j'étais dans une voiture dans une
voiture volée muet moi j'ai un jugement
il les a changés justifie rien moi j'ai
un jugement qui invite ce que je suis
fait rire mais il chose explique moi si
tu vu qui vous êtes tellement
intelligent vu que vous êtes tellement
locaux expliqué mi temps moi j'ai une
preuve qu'il n'y avait jamais fait que
le médecin des umj a attesté j'ai été
violée c'est tout ce que je reconnaisse
que plus de poids parce qu'il écrit par
rapport aux voiliers il y sort 2003
c'est du très moyen on va on va terminer
c'est la première fois que vous invitez
un policier dans une affaire en cours
d'accord c'est à dire que je peux
apporter la contradiction oui sauf que
moi j'ai un devoir réserve et surtout on
n'a pas le droit de parler d'une affaire
en cours donc du coup moi j'ai travaillé
plutôt sur les vidéos aujourd'hui mais
quand vous faites ce genre de débat
quand vous recevez des gens comme ça où
il n'y a pas de débat contradictoire on
a fait aujourd'hui non mais non mais
celle enquête soyez patients attendent l
enquête ne sauve pas des gens qui n'a
pas reparlé de cette affaire me mets pas
les angles c'est à dire qu'il faut
attendre l'anc est donc du coup mais
attendez mais quand ce gars là ils
étaient lâchés vous hier oui mais vous
avez des pères de famille vous pensez
aux policiers derrière la attendait non
mais oui mais c'est à dire vous pouvez
baisser nos maisons
on a dit qu'il a dit qu'il aurait porté
les honda déplorons l'adversité seront
bien pour la gagne et qu'on aurait la
version pure passion pourquoi voulu
faire un tribunal avant tribunal en fait
c'est un témoignage je vois leurs deux
alors là je veux faire venir un gars qui
va dire des conneries sur rhône à on a
et on a nommé personne mais j'ai pas dit
que vous avez là ça mais ça leur vous
vous trompez vous voulez aller trop vite
la justice soyez patient mois du gp part
dans mon coeur monsieur léger léger
peine je la porte pas dans mon coeur et
les policiers n'aime pas l'igpn parce
qu'en général travail à charge donc les
policiers on n'aime pas nous on est pour
une réforme de l'igpn dans mon syndicat
au niveau d'une réforme tout simplement
c'est parce que vous mettez pas les
meilleurs flics dans l'est la liche epn
voilà il ya des supers flics à l'igpn
mais aussi travail aussi voit comment
pour le pouvoir en place donc moi j'ai
une affaire avec des gilets jaunes avec
monsieur rodriguez qui a été bornier
c'est un policier qui est mise en cause
donc un petit mec comme ça de 30 ans qui
viennent 2000 bahts par mois et que que
l'igpn comment on fait une enquête à
charge et roman dsk quand même mais
c'est une vraie victime sûr mais il faut
trouver le vrai coupable dans la
broderie gueule et dans la sphère
rodrigues le vrai coupable c'est keith
l'administration alors que vous donner
un petit scoop allez encore une fois sur
touche pas à mon flic dans la sphère
rodriguez l'état a mis dans les mains
des policiers oui des grenades ou le ou
d'écouter des morceaux de fer qui peut
qui part dans tous les sens et c'est ça
qui est borné monsieur rodriguez vous
pensiez tous que c'était une bd et ben
non c'est pas une bd qui est borgne m
sur rodriguez et oui nous redit nous
regardent et bien écoutez moi j'aimerais
bien juste d'abord un je suis en
souffrance aussi pour monsieur rodriguez
parce que c'est une réelle souffrance
qu'il a eues mais maintenant c'est
l'état car laisser rentrer des black
blocs à laisser rentrer des black blocks
dans les manifs de ligue 2 de gilet
jaune on le sait tous on le sait tous
ils ont mis des petits flics en face
voilà toujours policier vous bien sûr
c'est toujours pour les avoir évoqué tôt
ou tard s'inquiétait parce qu'avec tout
ce que je balance même faire révoquer
mais moi j'ai aucun problème moi je me
reprends mes collègues
pas pour des pères de familles qui
souffrent là encore on en est encore
inquiets au tapis voilà et nous on
souffre de vous on souffre des gens qui
vous évite dépens de l'impunité
politiciens vous êtes un raciste on
n'attend
vous entendez cette histoire aujourd'hui
que le policier qui a été tué lors d'une
opération
anti drogue c'est inadmissible pour vous
vous êtes d'accord et quel est le
rapport entre janvier et juin s'est
passé au travers et les terroristes
désolé j'ai bien dit j'aime bien parce
que j'adore j'adore ce genre de débat
audi audi vous êtes cyrillique c'est moi
j'adore ce genre de débat vous savez
pourquoi j'adore ce genre de débat fait
enfin ce que vous dites mais j'adore
cela qu'on parle des violences
policières sur les mouvements sociaux
dans les quartiers populaires on nous
sort la carte terrorisme où nous sommes
intéressés par ces gangs et sert à rien
car si aujourd'hui comme je
vous ai dit c'est pas les gens de
laisser parler de l'intérêt je me
rappelais tommy juste dernière question
quand vous entendez que bruno dit que
vous avez menti qu'est ce que ça vous
fait ce qui est comme des excuses à
monsieur c'est qu'on m'a toujours dit
dans la vie à des applis si aujourd'hui
il se hâta leproux c'est un imbécile et
les choses je les remercie tous ici
présents qui ont apporté leur soutien
est une chose mais sera-t-elle du est un
médecin jusqu'à preuve du contraire pour
toutes ces personnes qui émet un doute à
cette histoire j'étais aux jmj j'ai bien
médecins spécialisés pas un faux
policier qui vient du il pas que sa
spécialisée a indiqué auto de la
troisième courage et tout dire qu'au
rapport avec ce qui avec les résultats
des examens
j'ai passé des examens à mal est ce que
vous savez ce que savez vous ne serez
jamais parce que vous serez jamais
victimes de viol chaque fois